leur armes la rue les manifestants
contre le mariage pour tous l'ont envahi
en nombre samedi dernier date de
l'adoption par l'Assemblée nationale du
premier article de la loi incriminée
15000 manifestants selon la police 22000
selon les organisateurs le rassemblement
à Versailles était d'ailleurs le plus
important au niveau nationale parmi eux
des responsables des différentes
communautés religieuses car leurs croyan
ne serait pas compatible avec le mariage
pour tous pour nous on va dire qu'il y a
deux types d'orphelin il y a l'orphelin
qui est qui émane de la tragédie humaine
il a perdu son père il a perdu sa mère
et il y a l'orphelin qui le nouvel
orphelin que l'institution française va
pondre aujourd'hui c'est l'institution
violente de la Constitution à savoir que
l'enfant va demain chercher son père ou
sa mère selon les cas il ne va pas le
trouver au-delà du mariage homosexuel
c'est donc surtout la question de
l'enfant qui mobilise les communautés
musulmanes catholiques et protestantes
refusent le droit à l'adoption par les
couples homosexuels et craignent
d'éventuelles dérives je suis là parce
qu'on sait très bien que cette loi une
fois qu'elle sera votée et bien ouvrira
la voie à la procréation médicalement
assisté pour les femmes et logiquement
par égalité des droits les hommes
demanderont la gestation pour autrui et
là dans les deux cas on est dans
l'adoption qui n'est pas une vraie
adoption et on est dans la
marchandisation du corps humain la
circulaire de Madame tobiran et la
preuve par neuf malgré tous ces
mensonges que la que la GPA est au
programme c'est évident le gouvernement
a cependant rappelé la semaine dernière
que la gestation pour autrui n'était pas
à l'agenda du quinena peu convaincu 8000
croyants et laïqu ont signé en marge du
rassemblement une pétition nationale
lancée par le maire d'ivers droite du
chîné pH Briot si le N 5000 signataires
est atteint le Conseil économique social
et environnemental devra étudier la
recevabilité de la
loi